good morning belief nation today's
message is life is about losing over to
you Mike Tyson what I found out in life
as life goes on life is about losing as
we get older we lose our hair we lose
our teeth we lose mothers fathers or
sisters and but it's the ones who
overcome they're lost in life and shun
away adversity and always willing to
fight it everybody a particular moment
in life are the ones that are able to
transcend and be able to spread the
world to other people who's in that same
particular gender as they are so what do
you think I agree with Mike the life is
about losing and it's also about what we
gained through those losses what we we
learn from them how we're able to help
others through their losses and inspire
them a few years ago I went through a
personal loss one of the biggest losses
I've experienced in my life and it was a
loss of a parent although it was a
really difficult experience it was also
one of the experiences that led me to
gain the most and learn the most about
myself about my family I learned how to
be more independent how to support my
family and then later on how to support
my friends through the same experience
even though I really really miss him I'm
thankful to have gotten through that
challenging time so that I can be
helpful to others but that's some
there's some deep heavy stuff and I'm
super grateful that I haven't lost my
parents yet but you know we're all gonna
go through that at some point I think
the key thing that I took from your
message and from Mike's too is that you
can easily be defined by the losses that
you've had you can either you can easily
say well I've lost all this stuff in my
life and then that keeps you down and
that becomes your story and you never
do anything for yourself or it can allow
you to be stronger and by you sharing
your story with other people you can
help them get through a lot of things
they're going through in their life as
well I think as entrepreneurs one of the
greatest things that you have is your
your story like why are you doing what
you're doing a lot of times it comes
from something negative that happen and
you turned it into a positive and by you
explaining your story and why is it so
important to you other people can learn
from that because they're probably going
through the same thing a lot of people
are too afraid to share they're like oh
I might be judged people might talk
about where they're going to think if I
tell them this you know I don't want to
make it about me and someone somebody
asks you a question it's always there
oh yeah I'm fine like this typical
answer where if you do get that
opportunity to go deeper with somebody
it can really not only make your
relationship with them stronger but also
help them get through potentially
something that's really deep and
meaningful and painful at that moment in
their life as well it's a good
opportunity to have a significant impact
on the lives of others so the question
the day today is what do you love most
about your dad it's a good question
maybe we should answer to what what do
you love most about your dad the thing
that I love the most with my dad was his
absolute commitment and dedication to
his family and for me my dad is just the
nicest human being you're ever gonna
meet like he'll sacrifice himself for
the good of others to his own detriment
but just like the nicest person that
you'll ever meet
I think on the face of this planet so
that's what I've built my dad what do
you love about your dad leave in the
comments below and we'll join in the
discussion thank you guys so much for
watching and have an amazing day
continue to believe and I'll see you
again tomorrow morning for another shot
a vinspresso
amigo